we've all seen it - gas stations on the
same street selling the same product but
at different prices variety and gas
prices can dictate the commuters route
to work or impact the cost of a family's
summer vacation Americans are keenly
aware of the impact gas prices can have
on their lives but all drivers have
probably wondered at some point
why do gas prices vary so much from
state to state town to town and
sometimes even block-to-block overall
gas prices are dictated by a combination
of global national and local economic
forces they vary depending on how those
forces add up we'll explain here's a
breakdown of where your money goes at
the pump the biggest factor that impacts
gas prices is the one you probably
expect the price of crude oil this
doesn't explain price differences from
pump to pump but it does explain why the
price of a gallon of gas can fluctuate
from day to day changes and gas prices
follow changes in oil prices oil prices
fluctuate for a variety of reasons first
they depend on the output from
oil-producing countries like the top
ones shown here if a major oil producer
like Saudi Arabia cuts production the
price could rise in fact the
Organization of Petroleum Exporting
Countries or OPEC sometimes does this on
purpose to raise the price of crude oil
other factors that affect the cost of
crude oil include speculation and
financial markets the amount of
stockpiled oil reserves geopolitical and
weather events and demand the United
States has the highest demand for crude
oil in the world consuming nineteen
point six million barrels per day this
demand is seasonal US oil demand
increases over the first half of the
year and peaks in summer months as
travel increases summer travel often
involves crossing state lines and gas
prices can vary substantially from state
to state those differences mostly have
to do with state taxes and refining
methods
there's a federal excise tax that
everyone pays but each state also levies
their own gas tax Pennsylvania drivers
pay over seventy seven cents per gallon
in taxes the nation's highest while
drivers in Alaska pay the lowest in
taxes at just over 32 cents per gallon
some of these taxes go to state
departments of transportation and over
the past decade more than two dozen
states have increased their tax rates to
fund infrastructure projects beyond
taxes fuel additives and refining
processes create price differences
between states most of the fuel sold and
the u.s. is ten percent ethanol coastal
states may see a 2 to 3 cent gas price
increase to cover the transportation
costs to ship the additive from the
nation's corn belt some states are also
required by law to use special
reformulated gasoline that reduces air
pollution it's currently used in 18
states and makes up about 30% of the
fuel sold in the US were formulated
gasoline was almost 30 cents more on
average than conventional gas in 2018
California has one of the highest gas
taxes and most stringent were formulated
gas programs in the country leading the
prices consistently above the national
average also very few facilities outside
of the state are equipped to refine its
specialized fuel when two of the state's
13 were formulated gas refineries
experienced outages in 2015
fuel had to be imported from overseas
driving up the price but what about that
few cents difference between neighboring
gas stations that often comes down to
marketing decisions made by station
owners the majority of gas stations in
the United States are privately owned
businesses station owners negotiate
contracts with fuel suppliers that cover
shipment frequency volume in branding
disruptions up the supply chain like a
refinery shutdown can impact stations
differently depending on the terms of
their contract which can lead to
different prices at different locations
but also profit margins on gas are low
compared to other goods sold at gas
stations like food and drinks after
expenses a station will take in an
average of 10 to 15 cents for
every gallon of gas sold according to an
industry trade group fuel accounts for a
majority of sales at gas stations but
only about 1/3 of profits station owners
make most of their money from in-store
purchases in a recent industry survey
over half of drivers said that the gas
price is the biggest factor when
deciding where to fill up a slightly
lower gas prices can increase customer
traffic to a store creating more
opportunities for owners to sell those
higher margin in-store items the cost of
a gallon of gas at any time is a
reflection of multiple economic forces
both large and small but gas stations
will always try to find a way to get
drivers to go that extra mile